hello and welcome and it's a pleasure
for me to welcome the president of the
european commission also the founder
lion to stockholm and here to stockholm
exergy and at this facility 90
of the general
district heating comes from renewable or
recycled fuels
and stockholm exergy is one of many
companies that put sweden in the
forefront of the green transition and is
also supported by the recovery plan here
in sweden
and all over sweden not at least up in
the northern part of our country we see
a new green industrial revolution taking
place
with battery
factories green battery factories fossil
free steel production and new green
standard for mining
and in the wake follow other companies
often innovative and fast growing
startups creating thousands of new jobs
now and also for the future
so with this
development we want to
lead the way in the european union and
in the world proving that the green
transition goes hand in hand with strong
growth and more jobs
and
i appreciate our close cooperation with
the commission not at least in the green
and digital transformation
but also
during the circumstances we're in right
now
responding to russia's war on ukraine
and we are witnessing an increased
russian brutality in ukraine and attacks
on civilian and civilians and civilian
infrastructure
and we see horrific images from butcher
and bombings of children's hospitals and
reports of executions of civilians in
mariopol
we see a new dark chapter in european
history
and there is clearly a time before and
after february 24th and the russia's
invasion of ukraine that is unprovoked
illegal and indefensible
and it's clear that the responsibility
for responsibility for the war is
solely on president putin and the
russian leadership
and our european response has been firm
and united
and the record time and with the very
hard work from the commission we have
imposed sanctions against russia that
are more far-reaching and more advanced
than almost any observer would have
deemed possible
and together with partners we're working
to further isolate the russian
leadership and we also from a swedish
perspective want to be very constructive
in the discussions of the fifth sanction
package of sanctions
we also remain committed to support
ukraine with humanitarian financial and
military aid and sweden has already
contributed with total
10 000 anti-tank weapons to ukraine but
we have also increased humanitarian aid
to ukraine with 72 million euros
and we stand ready for further use of
the european peace facility so that we
european countries can continue to
support
ukraine we also we act in solidarity
with ukraine but also in solidarity with
our common values international law
human rights democracy and european
security order
and
the president and i agree that the
international intentional attacks on
civilian population and civilian objects
it's a war crime and the russian
violation of international law
must be investigated and those
responsible will be brought to justice
and sweden we are supporting the
international criminal criminal court
financially but also with experts
the russian
invasion of ukraine has made it even
more urgent and necessary to become
independent of russian oil and gas and
we should speed up the climate work in
order to cut our dependence
and it is clear that breaking our
dependency on fossil fuel is important
to fight climate change but also to
strengthen our common security
to do this we have to secure the supply
of renewable energy we need to expand
wind power and also recognize the
importance of new green solutions based
on bioenergy and forestry
and in doing this we create sustainable
societies with high growth more jobs
today and tomorrow
and here at stockholm executive where we
are today is just one good example how
we can become independent of foreign
russian oil and gas and at the same time
advance the green transition
and finally i would like to thank the
commission for supporting our recovery
plan
those recovery plans will help the
european union to focus on green and
digital transition
so thank you
thank you
thank you prime minister dear magdalena
thank you very much thank you very much
for the very warm welcome
and indeed you are so right
we are living through bleak times
putin's ruthless war still rages in
ukraine
but our union stands very firmly with
the brave people of ukraine
beat with unprecedented sanctions
against the aggressor
be it with financial support for ukraine
but also through deliveries of military
equipment and humanitarian support for
people in ukraine
all the fact that the european union is
now catering for four million refugees
who had to leave their homes behind
the ukrainian people deserve
our solidarity
that's why i will travel to kiev
tomorrow i want to send a very strong
message of unwavering support to the
ukrainian people and their brave fight
for our common values
the atrocious war has now been going on
for over a month
our common european response to russia's
invasion in ukraine has been strong
it has been swiftly
coordinated and very determined
we have adopted with unprecedented speed
indeed four sanctions packages and the
fifth is underway as we're speaking here
coordinated with our partners the united
states
the united kingdom canada
overall the uh
we have now more than 40 countries that
are aligning
with our sanctions
and i want to thank you the magdalena
for the ongoing support that we receive
from you what the development of
sanctions is concerned
but indeed as you said the crisis has
also shed light on the dependencies
the that we have and we have absolutely
to get rid of them
the first one is the dependency on
russian fossil fuels
the european commission will therefore
in a short time it may present a plan to
phase out our dependency on russian gas
oil and coal so it has three components
we have to diversify away from russia
towards reliable
partners and suppliers like for example
the united states canada or japan
we have to
strengthen our energy efficiency that's
a big topic there's a lot of
room to maneuver for increased energy
efficiency and therefore save energy
and we have to invest massively in
renewables and here of course i know
that i can count on sweden's active role
as we all can see here sweden is a
renewable energy pioneer
renewables are bound to make up half of
your country's energy mix by the end of
the decade that's amazing
so we have to learn a lot from you
in this green transition
and this is why i'm particularly
grateful for this
invitation here to exergy
it was fascinating for me to listen to
the guided tour and to understand
how this is a perfect circular
approach towards district heating
a pilot project of carbon capture and
storage this is the future that we see
right now here
with a quantum leap in energy production
and of course a huge potential not only
for sweden but for the whole of the
european union
i think it's fascinating energy
production that absorbs carbon instead
of pushing it into the atmosphere
and giving a boost to our plans to reach
the climate neutrality by 2050 i know
that sweden has a more ambitious goal
with 2045.
so exergy has chosen to base its
production solely on renewable and
recovered energy resources
and i was fascinated to hear that you
have the potential to make stockholm
the world's first climate positive
capital city
so it's a fantastic and smart business
decision
it's good for the planet but it's also
good as a strategic investment in our
security of energy supply
in general it's high time for our
continent to build a more robust economy
first because it has been weakened by
two years of pandemic we should not
forget we are just getting out of the
pandemic
and also because a strong cohesive
economy and a competitive industry
with innovative technologies as we see
it here today are invaluable assets in a
turbulent world we live in
and this is where next generation eu
comes into play
it is as you know our recovery plan it's
our road map for reshaping the continent
for decades ahead we have the european
green deal as one priority
we have the second priority to
digitalize our economies and of course
the threat a third priority to increase
our resilience
next generation eu is 800 billion euros
focused on these priorities so i'm very
glad that today i can announce that the
european commission has given green
light
to sweden's recovery and resilience plan
let me describe a little bit what's in
it it's an excellent plan 44 of the plan
will support our climate and energy
priorities
investment in electrification
decarbonization of the industry energy
efficiency and residential buildings for
example
and with reforms promoting the increased
use of biofuels in the transport sector
also a very important topic
then you dedicate significant resources
to our second goal the digital
transition you are already very good so
from a high level you increase the
digitalization you are front runner
20 of this plan's budget are dedicated
to the digitalization
you will give a boost to maintain your
leadership of course in this field and
i'm very glad to see that more than 460
million euros
will be invested in the roll out
of high-speed broadband throughout the
country
and that the plan also includes
significant investment in digital skills
smart technology for energy efficiency
and in more efficient and accessible
public services
so the commission's approval opens the
way to the disbursement of 3.3 billion
euros over the next years
and i have now the pleasure to
let you know green light and
the work we've done so far does not end
here but it starts in implementing the
plan many things
agency mrs prime minister uh finland
sims about to move forward and get into
the process of applying for nato
membership um how do you feel this will
influence sweden's decision to follow
that path and
can one imagine that both finland and
sweden's applications would be
considered at the same time
well i mean there's uh there is a
process in finland in the finnish
government and in the finnish parliament
and we have very close contacts with
them
we also have a process in sweden and in
in the swedish parliament and government
i mean we have already decided in sweden
after the russia's invasion of ukraine
we have already decided to increase our
military spending to 2 percent of gdp
and speed up
uh our investments and
on top of that we have deepened our
partnership with nato uh but we're now
having discussions uh with the foreign
minister and the defense ministers with
all the parties in the swedish
parliament on making a new analysis of
the security situation for sweden right
now and what
we will find is the best way forward to
sweden of course we have very close
contact with finland and when they're
processed since
we do have a close cooperation in many
areas including in the defense area
i got a question to president from the
lion
about sanctions would you accept or even
welcome if sweden stops importing gas
and oil from russia
without awaiting a
decision from the european union
i think we have been
very successful in the last 44 days
by being united and moving forward
together as one union
after the invasion on day two four and
six we
presented the first three packages of
sanctions now today it's the fifth
package
behind these packages is and tremendous
excellent work
of
combining the knowledge from the
different member states and our goal to
severely impact negatively the russian
economy and the russian financial sector
so my plea is always that we move
forward together
and it's worth
really to coordinate among the member
states because then the power of the
sanctions is higher and the impact is
stronger
sorry i also got a question for um
this one elaine as well on the proposed
oil embargo is there any timeline you
can give on how long the discussions are
going to take we're talking days or
weeks or months
i think we're going to be done with the
discussions within hours
so today or tomorrow
swedish television a question for mrs
van der lion
what
course of action will the european union
take if hungary opposes
sanctions on the energy sector
and tries to stop that and
mrs anderson are you ready to let sweden
go ahead with sanctions even if the rest
of the european union does not
so
so far all 27 member states stood firmly
to the sanctions and we have no
indication that this is not the case for
the next ones
let me tell you that we're working
already very hard on the next
package of sanctions
and we continue to prepare with the
member states
the next step and we are looking
intensively at the moment being at oil
so to prepare to be able to face out of
oil
another topic we are discussing
right now among the member states is
the demand of
putin to pay the bill
in ruble
we have had a very detailed legal
analysis
of that decree
that he issued and we believe that this
proposed ruble exchange
is not only a high risk for the
companies involved but it would also be
a civil conventions
circumvention of the existing sanctions
so you see from my description that we
are constantly with the member states
already now working on the next phase
and really looking in depth what the
best approach is to hit as hard as
possible the russian economy
but to be as coherent and coordinated as
possible within the european union
i think that during these weeks our
unity has been a very very strong
message towards russia so from a swedish
perspective we really want to work
together with the other member states to
move forward on the next package and we
are trying to be a very constructive
partner cooperating with the commission
to
to argue for further sanctions because
we are definitely willing to go forward
with for the sanctions from a swedish
perspective
here we go
you